foreign
let's go to Sarah in Louisville Kentucky
what's up Sarah
hey how are you good one time I called
it Louisville and I did not end well
yeah so don't do that I'm out of the
hospital now and it's Louisville
that's right that's right what's up
um so my question is when do you push
through hard conversations with a new
friend and when do you just let that
friendship go
just let It Go Don't hold back anymore
uh that's the great Elsa saying
um okay give me more context
so I had a neighbor who wants to be
friends and
and including her in my friend group but
that has caused um some issues for
example I invited her to girls night and
um she ended up talking so much that a
couple people suggested they either talk
to her about making sure the
conversation's more Equitable or not
inviting her anymore
um I'm a little afraid of how that
conversation would go if I did talk to
her especially because she does already
seem to be aware that she dominates
conversation
and as far as not inviting her goes I've
been that girl without friends before
and I really don't want to just abandon
someone who's lonely yeah
yeah
um
oh man making friends as an adult is the
worst it's the worst I know when you
were a little kid you just had to be the
same age they just I know it's like hey
we're playing kickball and there was
either the Nerds that loved kickball or
the kids that were like I hate kickball
and they had their Hello Kitty backpack
and their little uh Trapper Keepers and
they would just be ironic and like but
you just like found your friends and now
there's neighbors and it's like oh
you're weird you're weird
um how do you know that she knows that
she dominates conversations
because she'll say stuff like sorry I'm
talking so much or she'll say sorry I
talked so much tonight I'm just really
excited or things like that so she's
she's very aware that she's talking a
lot but you so desperately want to be
like well then how about you stop I was
just
Hey listen listen it is not your
responsibility
as just a human on planet Earth to take
in all of the cases of loneliness in the
world and make them yours to solve okay
so I want you to I want to relieve you
of that I also think there are some
low-fi ways to solve some of this
potentially okay okay so I'm gonna send
you a whole bunch of questions for
humans cards
and here's why my my wife said she loves
these things and here's why
I talk too much a lot I talk way too
much and I got opinions on everything
especially when we're just hanging out
just with a couple friends and whatever
and
she said when you're going through these
cards everybody gets a turn so somebody
has to stop talking
and it lets other people tell their
story and
a good friend thing is when somebody
else is telling a story and the person
who has to always be heard
starts talking someone go hey hold on
let her finish and they're little things
like that that aren't rude or not you
being a jerk or anything like that but
they're just subtle quiet like hold on
hold on I want to hear this story
is a oh yeah okay yeah you see what I'm
saying and it doesn't have to be
dramatic and big but it's just a quick
like hold on I want to hear what she has
to say about this I do that in
administrative meetings sometimes in
meetings there's two or three people
that talk all the time and there's three
or four people who are really quiet who
have lots of great ideas but they don't
say anything I'll stop back hold on hold
on I've already heard from you I want to
hear from so and so and I'm just pretty
direct about it and I don't think
anybody thinks it's mean or ugly or rude
um it's just I want other voices to be
heard and sometimes just
doing a little bit of quarterbacking can
someone can slowly get the message and
learn does that make sense
yeah wouldn't that be more for like if
she was interrupting somebody though
that she's interrupting people who are
already talking it's that
you know anything that comes up she has
a better story for it do you know what I
mean it's not like a oh no stop with
that let's hear from you know what I
mean yes and better story people are
really tough they're really tough like
oh yeah well one time I like all right
all right oh yeah yeah
that means hard I mean I I don't know
there's an easy way through it I do
think with some if I'm in your situation
I would probably attempt some modeling
and if
um
and it may be that there's certain
friends like I've got certain friend
groups that I hang out with there's I go
watch the fights with a group of guys
and I play music with a different group
of guys
yeah just different they're just
different folks who do different things
I thought about that too
um just she said that she enjoyed the
girls night so much she was like this
was amazing it was awesome and she knows
I do it regularly
so if she doesn't get invited again yeah
she's an adult and she has her she is in
control of her feelings
you are allowed to have events at your
house with the people that you choose to
have events with
okay choose guilt over resentment every
time
so you wouldn't even try to talk to her
about no I would I totally would
I would when you approach that like I
said I would I would do something like
hey we're gonna play a game a directed
game or like I'm gonna send you the the
girls night cards and the questions for
humans friends I'm gonna send those to
you and you can pass them out and be all
right everybody's gonna answer one and
then we're gonna go around the room
the hard part is we did something very
similar to that I had everybody write
down two things about themselves and
then everyone had to guess who those
things were so we did kind of go around
the room and um so some people got some
time to talk just
it still ended up like a one up and then
a one up you know
I think I think that that's your job is
to to play quarterback and to model
something new which is after the first
one up and the second one up when she
starts to one-up somebody else go hold
on hold on we're gonna go to the next
card
okay all right you see what I'm saying
yeah
yeah I I that's that's what I would do
if I have I mean uh
yeah that's just hard I wish there was
any way man that's just not an easy way
it's just tough
um
I can also see a scenario where this is
very much like the you got a booger in
your nose conversation
and
um like I can't think of a more graceful
honorable thing than when someone like
pulls me aside it's like hey dude you
gotta poker in your nose
I got so kind and lovely even though
we're both gonna be weird now
like because I want to be like why are
you looking up my nose weirdo and B
thank God somebody told me right and so
it may be like hey we're gonna grab
coffee and like hey it's gonna be weird
and awkward and hard and you're my
friend now and so I just want to tell
you
um
like everybody who tells a story you
always have a one-up story and a better
story that's just making it make it hard
okay and that might be an awkward
conversation but it can't be any more
Awkward than what you're feeling right
now at least you'd have some resolution
right yeah yeah that's true at least and
she might tell you you know what I you
go to hell I hate you and I'm gonna
bring your house down when you're when
you're on vacation she might say that
and she might be like okay thank you so
much finally somebody told me right
yeah
yeah I did wonder if just nobody had had
the courage to have that conversation
and just kind of opted out instead and
that's why she doesn't have many friends
and it becomes self-reinforcing right
she feels people pulling away and so
then she tries to tell more stories to
keep them engaged and then they start to
pull away more until she gets louder and
faster and be like oh yeah well one time
I and it's just a symptom of wanting to
be a part of what's going on and yeah
somebody doesn't feel whole enough it
doesn't feel worthy enough that their
presence is enough like the fact that
you showed up and brought dip and or
beers or whatever you brought that's not
enough you have to you're only loved
because you got another story to tell
and it's communicating no no I'm really
glad you're here and you're making it
hard to for us to want you to stay here
this is tough okay yeah and the people
in my life who've had that conversation
with me on a number of issues I think so
so highly of them
my buddy Trevor when I was in college
like when me and the person who's my
wife now when we broke up I was like she
said this and this and he was like dude
you're an idiot
and I was like what do you mean and he
said it way more colorful than that but
he was right he called me out and it
literally changed I didn't see it from
my perspective when he saw like dude I'm
your body I'm your roommate and this is
I see how you treat people dude it was
eye-opening for me I've had bosses Dr
Thompson did this for me Mike Gibson did
this for me I've had people all through
my life pull me aside Dave Ramsey's done
that for me like hey here's a thing I
see in you and it can be really great
and it can also be really isolating and
so every time somebody's done that it's
hard to hear it really is but what a
gift man it's such a blessing when
somebody has the courage to do that so
um
again in a Publix Forum like with a
bunch of people around that's not the
place but a private quiet conversation
might be the place I would do it after
getting some cards and being real direct
and having some some time during this
time like during the event where you're
like oh hold on a second I'm gonna let
so and so talk I want to let Ben talk I
want to let Kelly talk I want to let
Christian talk like I I want to let them
I want to hear what they have to say and
give somebody a picture of what it looks
like to just sit through it
um and not have to comment on everything
um and then after that if it keeps up
and keeps up it keeps up maybe it's
worth a worth the conversation
choose guilt over resentment
choose guilt over resentment every
single time every time
you're awesome Sarah best of luck to you
making adult friends is the worst